if I could retire I would just leave it  here because it was so gratifying and so  fun I mean the scripts are spectacular  all those dynamics kind of are the same  but even better the depth the show has  now is kind of it's grown up a little  bit is the way we have so to me it was  my favorite thing I've ever done we were  so excited that Melissa McCarthy was  coming back me too as a friend back in  the day I'd worked with her during the  day and then go see her at Groundlings  at night and I was like this is a  off-the-charts talent that she has that  it's so gratifying to see how it's  translated and to have her back on set  and it was their last day or  second-to-last day it was beautiful